it's been 30 days since
uranus first appeared in the sky at
first it
looked like our moon had found itself a
stellar partner
but then we understood something
much much bigger was headed our way
what caused uranus to become so unstable
how could this epic collision change the
ice giant
oh and what's this horrific stink
ugh this
is what if and here's what would happen
if uranus
collided with earth
let's roll back 30 days when things were
still normal
uranus lived a quiet life on the
outskirts of our solar system
about 3 billion kilometers away from us
and then suddenly it began to move
closer astronomers would be the first to
push the panic button
by their calculations it would take
uranus
13 years to reach the collision point
we'd be short on time but at least we'd
have a slight chance to evacuate the
earth
but the cold blue giant had other plans
in mind
this would be no standard planetary
drill
planets don't just take off from their
orbits
for no reason at all but somehow uranus
did
now it would be hurtling through the
solar system
ramping up to a speed of around 1 000
kilometers per second
because of this unexpectedly fast speed
we'd only have about 30 days left on
this planet
uranus would shine like a bright blue
star in the sky
and every day it would appear bigger and
brighter
our sky would look gorgeous not only
because of the ice giant
shining down on us but also thanks to
many shooting stars
only those wouldn't be stars at all
to get to the earth's orbit uranus would
have to pass
an asteroid belt between jupiter and
mars
this would disrupt the stable orbits of
many asteroids and
throw some of them our way these
asteroids can be as big as 240
kilometers in diameter
that's a few times larger than the one
responsible for
wiping dinosaurs off the face of the
earth about 65 million years ago
we would have nowhere to go we'd just be
left here watching the end of times
unfold in front of our eyes
huh might as well enjoy the view
by the time the first asteroids appeared
as shooting stars
uranus would look about the same size as
the moon
but it would be growing rapidly as it
moved
ever closer while you'd be here
awaiting humanity's doom uranus
would start shaking things up
because uranus is about 15 times
more massive than the earth its
gravitational pull
would start massively affecting our
planet
volcanoes would begin erupting
uncontrollably
and tremendous earthquakes would get in
on the act
destroying the earth from the inside
and the stink you drop unconscious from
even
one whiff of it because well i mean
uranus smells like farts
the ice giant's upper atmosphere is
mostly composed
of hydrogen sulfide it's the same stuff
that makes
rotten eggs ring so bad imagine an
entire planet of rotten eggs
engulfing the earth
the thought of it makes me nauseous
[Music]
but uranus wouldn't come alone
it would bring all of its 27 moons along
for the ride
and those moons would be hitting the
earth from all sides
as a fart filled finale uranus would
compress
what was left of our atmosphere and the
rapidly rising temperatures
would ignite it just like that
our beautiful blue planet would fall in
line and
start circling the ice giant eventually
becoming one of its many moons
uranus wouldn't get away with this
assault so easily however
last time it collided with another
planetary object twice the size of earth
it tipped over yeah uranus is the only
planet in our neighborhood that
spins on its side
[Music]
this impact featuring our earthly home
could help tilt it back to how it once
was
but for the earth we know that would be
it
if by some unexplained mystery
life on earth's stinking leftovers
emerged once again
we would see the blue of uranus on the
horizon
it would look just as cool as if the
earth was one of jupiter's moons
but that's a story for another
what if
[Music]